i like american football i just don't
understand why it's called football
because they don't use their feet yeah
it should be causally different maybe
throw ball
whatever you want to call it throw it
you don't kick it
you do kick it yeah once yeah
we like like a face off i know we're
supposed to be a team right
i hope we agree on everything okay
pineapple on pizza is delicious
i don't understand why people get so
scared of pineapple on paper
no
that's unnatural although pineapple
pizza is called hawaiian pizza it was
actually invented in canada
yeah no little general knowledge for you
though thank you it was but i like it i
would never normally order it but if
someone presented to me pineapple pizza
on set and i was hungry so you strongly
agree with it
i'll go here i'll go here yeah i was
like because you're acting like you just
i love loving i can't remember the last
time i had pineapple on pizza to be fair
that is true yeah i've never in my life
ordered a pineapple pizza i don't even
think i've eaten a few like i don't
think i've even had a piece of with
pineapple on it i thought you could say
a piece of pineapple i was like
no i love pineapple but i don't like it
on my pizza i'll tell you that next one
before we have a fight yeah
american football is better than soccer
three
two
one
yeah i disagree too
i don't think i mean
i like american football i just will
never remember dangerous why it's called
football
because they don't use their feet i just
don't understand why it's called
football yeah it should be causally
different maybe throw ball
whatever you want to call it
don't kick
i like american football and i can
respect the athleticism and the
strategic aspects of the sport but
football
is the greatest sport of all time i mean
it is it is the world sport and you know
we went to the band all the other day
and we met messi and it was crazy
it was crazy
and we met ambape i actually asked them
buffet i said hey nice to meet you he
was really friendly i said mate you have
to come to tottenham
and he just burst out laughing
i don't really know what any of that
means
but for sure
food is better than british food
i don't really i don't know i haven't
had enough of y'all's food
i think that you know i like the food we
got but i don't know if anything like we
do american food what is that what is
american food though like hot dogs
american chocolate
oh it's got to be british chocolate
really i don't know trust me
but like not enough to like really like
well and you actually have some here
jaffa cakes can't go wrong with a japa
cake
wow that was really good
never had a jaffa cake
would you like one sure
it's uh like an orange
no
i don't like orange flavored things
i actually don't
don't know
darnell
try it though it's not orange flavored
it's actually got orange in it yeah
orange chocolate not for me
try try try try it
it's double tasty
that don't smell right
smell it smell it just make it give it
in my mouth give it a smell
i can smell it because it's in my mouth
that doesn't smell very good
you haven't got to the orange bit yet
though oh that's going to be the worst
no no no no you're done it's not it's
not my style
this is not my vibe
it's like if you can make something that
you don't want
make how would make this
okay
okay
okay
it's got orange filling okay so what
would you say would be your american
inside what's the inside of this orange
jelly
no
no no no absolutely and i take these
last time would you like mine sure okay
london best city in the world
three well i know what you're gonna say
one
i think that london is a beautiful place
yes and i love it here
um but there's also other beautiful
places in the world
i'm sitting right now
oh are you not i'm actually going to go
with agree because i haven't been to all
the cities in the world and you know
lots of places have assets that london
doesn't have like you go to barcelona
you have the beach you know yeah um
and that's it so maybe it's just
possible
he's trying to sound like i'm really
cultured i'm like
madrid is also in spain
right guys
this hasn't been anywhere um no i love
london london is my home i've grown up
here whenever i come back
it feels like i'm a part of the city
it's a great city great food lovely
people can you tell that he's english
just from this interview can you tell uh
your favorite place in london
i can't tell you that because then
people will go there and try and find it
is the best spider-man three i'm not
getting in trouble yeah i'm not getting
in trouble
i'm leaving it right there part of me
wanted to just flip the table then but i
was worried the legs might bang your
feet
um
just right there just leave it up to the
people yeah
it's not for us son tell us home best
quality is a spider best quality spot
sorry
best colonies i know
yeah
um
best quality is a spider-man
um i would say handsome
i would say um i mean there's a lot of
great things i think that make you
spider-man i think one of them is that
you actually love being spider-man yeah
like and you embrace it so much i think
anyone who's ever seen him you know deal
with kids especially when he's in the
out the the whole get up you know the
suit it's really special to watch you
know he does the accent and
does the web thing because i was like
can you shoot a web he's like
i've used all my web cartridges getting
here you know it's it's really really
sweet you know um so that i would also
say that you have the annoying
capability of doing everything very well
thank you um thank you
i don't know if anybody ever saw the
thing battle i'm still feeling the
respect of that should still hurt he
told me that he was just gonna we were
just gonna keep it chill and then there
was rain ah the rain came in quite late
though there was rain and there was a
wardrobe change so i didn't see that
coming this time to play i thought we
were you know i thought we were working
together but it's whatever um he has
this annoying capability of being able
to do everything really well so it's
like when you're when you're watching
him flip and then land and then fight
and then do all these things you know
you're you're great at it and you do it
with such ease
chairs
okay i like it when you have like a
gangster come on
yeah well that's a very different vibe
today what's it like when you interview
that gangster there terrifying yeah i
bet it
people said call me a gang so i didn't
like it one guy called me gangster stuff
stuck a gun in his mouth and educated
him that i weren't a gangster
and i said that i'm a businessman and my
business is crime someone sent me you
know do you want to come on an armed
robbery
i went yeah all right
i'm only sort of like 16 17.